Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Fünf Spieltage sind in der Premier League gespielt und die Champions League geht ja auch schon los. Höchste Zeit mal auf die Premier League zu blicken. Und das machen wir mit Joachim Hebel, der Kommentator bei Sky ist jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Joachim, hi, schön, dass du mal im Rasenfunk deine Premiere gibst.
Ja, das freut mich. Ich danke für die Einladung natürlich.
Sehr, sehr schön. Wir hatten deinen Bruder schon hier, falls sich das jetzt der ein oder andere da draußen gefragt hat. Ja, es gibt zwei Hebels und sie kennen sich beide mit der Premier League aus. Unglaublich.
Eine mehr, der andere weniger, aber immerhin.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich weiß es auch gar nicht wissentlich, dass du gerade unter den Schäfe stellen wolltest. Aber wir werden gleich hören, dass ihr beide euch sehr, sehr gut auskennt in der Premier League. Du kommentierst hier auch unter anderem bei Sky in diesem Jahr. Und wenn ich mir die Tabelle jetzt einfach mal von oben nach unten angucke, dann sehe ich, dass es eine Mannschaft gibt, die hat die weißeste aller weißen Westen in der Premier League. Auch wenn es jetzt in der Champions League ein 0 zu 2 in Neapel gab. Ich spreche natürlich vom FC Liverpool. 5 Siege aus 5 Spielen, 15 zu 4 Tore. Ist denn das auch alles so marktlos angelaufen, wie sich jetzt rein die Ergebnisse lesen?
Also ehrlich gesagt nicht so 100%ig. Also Liverpool hat eine sehr durchwachsende Vorbereitung hingelegt. In der letzten Saison war die Vorbereitung überragend und sie sind dann so ein bisschen wackelig gestartet. Diese Saison war eine sehr gute Vorbereitung. Da hatten sie eigentlich auch die Hoffnung, dass es besser reingeht in die Saison. Es kamen dann aber auch so ein klein wenig – also natürlich 5 Siege sind 5 Siege, Respekt. Aber sie haben natürlich auch schon Gegentore gespielt. Und zwar, ich glaube, jetzt in 4 von 5 Spielen haben sie kassiert. Und das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen zu viel. Letzte Saison waren es insgesamt 22 Gegentore. Das ist eigentlich überragend, wenn man sich mal das überlegt. Gerade für eine Mannschaft, die so offensiv eigentlich auch ausgerichtet ist. Also da ist die Balance quasi fast perfekt gewesen. Und jetzt kassieren sie schon immer mal wieder ein. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie eben hinten manchmal nicht so stehen, wie man sich das vorstellt. Gerade über die Außen, also Trent Alexander-Arnold und Ed Watson, sind des Öfteren mal ein bisschen zu offensiv erwischt worden und dann quasi schon überspielt gewesen. Und auch Van Dijk hat – das ist schon ein Fehler, klingt immer so, als wäre er – aber er stand auch nicht immer richtig. Da gab es auch so ein paar Aktionen, die man ihm angekreidet hat auf der Insel. Und dementsprechend hinten ist die Balance noch ein bisschen zu finden. Aber das Personal ist so gut, dass sie das mit Sicherheit auch hinbekommen werden, bin ich mir fast sicher.
Hatten ja unter anderem auch schon gegen Arsenal gespielt. Das war so einer von den Top-Mannschaften, mit denen man sich gemessen hat. Aber jetzt auch dieses 0 zu 2 in Neapel, was da so ein bisschen auch Erinnerungen weckt. Also irgendwie auswärts in der Champions League, das ist nicht so ganz das für Liverpool und in Neapel erst recht nicht. Da kommen so gewisse Erinnerungen an die letzte Champions League-Saison hoch. Hat sich denn im Fußball von Liverpool irgendwas verändert im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr? Oder ist das Problem eher, dass man es noch nicht geschafft hat, auf dem Level wieder anzukommen, wie im letzten Jahr? Aber der Fußballstil ist eigentlich gleich.
Also ich glaube schon, dass es eher Letzteres ist. Der Stil ist schon eher gleichgeblieben, ja. Das ist natürlich schon eine Mannschaft, die versucht natürlich, den Ball wieder hoch zu bekommen und dann sofort den Konter einzufangen. Das ist so nach wie vor. Aber dann natürlich so richtig rollen tut es noch nicht, was die Defensive betrifft. Und ich glaube, wenn sie das hinbekommen und da einfach wirklich wieder auch so ein bisschen dann in diesen Flow kommen, dann wird das wieder ein ähnlicher Fußball. Also ich glaube nicht, dass diese Mannschaft nicht unter den ersten Zwei landen wird. Dementsprechend, das wird schon wieder hervorragend laufen.
Okay. Und gibt es irgendwelche Spieler, die sich jetzt besonders in den Vordergrund gespielt haben? Also ich sehe Mohamed Salah, vier Tore, Sadio Mane wieder vier Tore. Gibt es noch jemanden darüber hinaus?
Die beiden waren ja so ein bisschen in der Kritik. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast. Mohamed Salah ist allein vom Tor gestanden gegen Burnley und hätte eigentlich rüberlegen können auf Mane, der stand noch besser und hat aber den Abschluss selbst gesucht. Darauf gab es einen riesengroßen Streit, den die Medien vom Zaun gebrochen haben. In England sei Salah einfach zu eigensinnig. Arsene Wenger ist darauf eingesprungen und so weiter und so fort. Die beiden können aber ganz gut miteinander und sind momentan auch gut drauf jeweils. Mane hat einfach überragend, wie er den Raum deutet, wie er in die Tiefe geht, wie er wirklich auch versteht, was das Spiel jetzt braucht. Salah, jemand, der eigentlich – heißt es immer – eigensinnig ist, kurioserweise aber die besten Werte hat, was das betrifft, von Salah auf Mane zu spielen. Also, das heißt, Mane-Chancen werden meistens von Salah eingeleitet. Wer mich aber am meisten beeindruckt hat am Wochenende, das war Roberto Firmino, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Der kommt rein, sitzt auf der Bank, kommt rein und gibt dem Spiel gleich was ganz anderes. Also, er lässt sich mal fallen, nimmt mal einen Ball an, dreht sich erstmal, wartet, dann denken alle, ah, okay, jetzt nimmt er so ein bisschen den Gang raus, spielt den Ball dann aber so dynamisch und perfekt in die Gasse, dass er eigentlich das Tempo verdreifacht. Das war bei dem 2 zu 1, glaube ich, von Mane so. Und beim 3 zu 1 von Salah war es dann, das war ja Wahnsinn. Das ist irre. Also, da wäre ich wirklich fast vom Stuhl gefallen.
Also, das war eine Vorlage, die mit der Hacke hinter dem Standbein vorbeizieht. Vielleicht haben der eine oder andere Hörer und Hörer das auch schon in den sozialen Netzwerken gesehen. Das wurde oft gegiftet, sozusagen.
Und mein Zitat dann auch verbreitet im Nachgang.
Was hast du denn dazu gesagt? Ich habe es lautlos gehört, hätte ich gesagt.
Dass ich – wie habe ich gesagt – zurücklehnen, Gin Tonic trinken und das Tor genießen, war mein Satz und das war einfach so aus der Hose geschossen. Ich dachte dann am Ende, so witzig fand ich es gar nicht und wurde aber bei zwei Portalen rauf und runter gespielt, tatsächlich. Mit Zitattafeln und so weiter.
Aber ist doch schön, wenn sich sowas auch für den Kommentator ergibt. Fünf Punkte hinter Liverpool aktuell schon Manchester City und da werden jetzt viele mitbekommen haben. Die Niederlage gegen Norwich, über die wir dann auf jeden Fall auch sprechen müssen im Verlauf dieser Sendung. Aber lass mal mit City anfangen. Von Anfang an war es ja das Duell um die Meisterschaft. Es scheint sich jetzt auch schon wieder genauso darzustellen. Wo hakt es bei City noch?
Ja, also kurioserweise ist da auch die Defensive. Also Pep Guardiola hat aktuell nur einen richtig fitten Innenverteidiger. Laporte ist verletzt, dann Stones ist noch nicht richtig fit, Compagnita hat den Verein ja verlassen. Auch da ist es eben genau das Problem, dass hinten einfach die Balance noch überhaupt nicht da ist. Natürlich haben sie mit Rodri auch einen neuen Spieler integriert in die Mannschaft, der auch erst noch richtig sich einfinden muss. Das ist halt einfach noch so ein bisschen der Unterschied. Vorne läuft's, Stirling überragende Werte, Aguero überragende Werte, Kevin de Boijne für mich persönlich eigentlich der beste Spieler der Liga momentan, auch wenn Play of the Month Temu Pukki geworden ist, aber was der macht, ist immer so ein bisschen verborgen, aber eigentlich überragend. Also vorne ist eigentlich alles okay. Hinten, das ist eben was Pep Guardiola glaube ich überhaupt nicht haben kann, dass es defensiv einfach sehr löchrig ist momentan.
Dabei lässt man die wenigsten Schüsse der Liga aufs eigene Tor zu, 6, 2 im Schnitt. Zum Vergleich, Liverpool ist da bei 10 pro Stück, also dann schon zweistellig. Hat sich da jetzt auch so ein bisschen Pech aufsummiert, auch mit so einem Spiel wie eben das bei Norwitsch, wo dann auch irgendwie alles zusammenkommt, der Gegner in perfekter Form mit dem Spieler aktuell, der eben gerade neben Kevin De Bruyne natürlich die Liga dominiert. Und dann fängst du eben halt auch einfach die drei Tore und rennst den dann hinterher? Oder steckt da jetzt mehr dahinter?
Ja, also es war ja gegen Tottenham schon so ein bisschen unglücklich. Das kann halt passieren. City ist eigentlich dafür bekannt, Spiele zu dominieren. Das war da auch wieder so. Sie haben 70 Prozent Ballbesitz gehabt. Sie haben 25 zu 7 Schüsse insgesamt gehabt. Und das ist einfach momentan dann so ein bisschen das Problem, wenn du drei Schüsse aufs Tor kriegst und du kriegst die alle drei. Ja, das glaube ich, ist kaum eine Mannschaft irgendwo in der Weltspitze, die davon dann nicht getroffen wird.
Also so eine kurzzeitige Delle. Jetzt habe ich ein paar Berichte gelesen, die thematisiert haben, dass Manchester City eben nicht in der Verteidigung nachgelegt hat. Natürlich ist es jetzt so ein bisschen Ex-Post-Berichterstattung. Also jetzt, wo die Innenverteidiger verletzt ausfallen und nur noch ein gelernter zur Verfügung steht, dann holt man das natürlich auch gerne raus. Andererseits ist es natürlich ein Punkt, dass mit Liverpool jemand mit Van Dijk, auf den sogar eine Saison lang noch gewartet hat und dann eine sehr, sehr hohe Summe für ihn bezahlt hat und mit Matthias de Ligt, der zum Beispiel auch ein anderer Spieler mit sehr hoher Qualität jetzt im europäischen Fußball gewechselt ist und das auffällt, dass City in der Abwehr nicht so hoch investiert wie eben bei den Offensivspielern. Siehst du da eine grundsätzliche Philosophie oder ist das halt jetzt die Diskussion, die halt geführt wird, weil es jetzt gerade so viele Verletzungen gibt in der Verteidigung?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist schon eine Mischung aus beidem ein bisschen. Also, letzte Saison hat er ja ausgegeben wie ein Verrückter in der Verteidigung. Vielleicht dachte er, das reicht, das kann natürlich sein. Dann natürlich, wenn du Stones und Laporte fit hast, sind das wahrscheinlich mit die besten Innenverteidiger der Welt auf einem absolut vernünftigen Alterslevel, also eher sogar noch jung. Und das könnte dir schon reichen. Wenn du dann noch sagst, ich habe ja auch der Mandy noch als Backup und ein Fernandinho, der es auch spielen kann, eventuell sogar ein Cancello, dann ist es ja auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so übel. Vielleicht sagst du dann auch noch, wir haben eh 70 Prozent Ballbesitz, die drei Mal, die der Gegner uns anläuft. Aber das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen naiv, so ein bisschen. Also auf der Insel wurde er stark kritisiert dafür, dass es eben eine naive Transferpolitik gewesen sei, dass er eben hätte mehr machen müssen. Und ja, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, hinten ist schon ein bisschen dünn. Also wie gesagt, jetzt sieht man es ja, Stones ist noch absolut nicht bei 100 Prozent, überhaupt nicht. Und der Mendy, der ist eigentlich auch nicht Weltklasse. Das ist ein überdurchschnittlicher Spieler, aber nicht Weltklasse. Und dann siehst du halt momentan, was du dafür bekommst. Also die werden einfach zu oft überspielt, stehen zu oft falsch und dann kreierst du Gegentore.
Wo würdest du denn sagen, steht der Stellenwert der Premier League für Manchester City im Vergleich zur Champions League? Also natürlich sagen sie, dass sie alles gewinnen wollen, das ist ja völlig klar. Aber wie nimmst du das wahr? Wenn ich mir jetzt die Gruppe anschaue, das ist mit Xachto Donets, mit Atalanta Bergamo und Zagreb. Also da sollte City dann knapp durchkommen, würde ich sagen. Aber was glaubst du? Welcher Wettbewerb ist da gerade derjenige, auf den dann das Team auch fokussiert?
Champions League schon über allem. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwiefern Pep Guardiola in der täglichen Arbeit jetzt quasi priorisiert und sagt, also der Samstag ist uns egal, konzentriert euch mal auf den Dienstag. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwiefern Pep Guardiola das wirklich priorisiert. Also dass er sagt, am Dienstag ist mir wichtiger als am Samstag und bitte konzentriert euch mal darauf. Aber man kann schon irgendwo bis zum gewissen Zeitpunkt erkennen, dass ihm die Champions League wichtig ist. Er selbst sagt in Pressekonferenzen eigentlich immer, dass die Liga ist unser tägliches Brot, das was eigentlich jeder Trainer sagt. Aber die Champions League hängt schon immer so ein bisschen über ihm. Und das ist natürlich auch das, was die Medien daraus machen. Er hat die Meisterschaft jetzt zweimal am Stück gewonnen, zweimal am Stück wirklich auch mit unfassbaren Rekorden, die er immer wieder gebrochen hat. Und dann ist natürlich klar, dass irgendwann auch mal erwartet wird, die Champions League zu gewinnen. Auf der Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel, das ich letztens kommentiert habe, da hat er eigentlich nur ganz kurz gesagt, die Champions League zu gewinnen ist sicherlich schön, aber ich nehme mich jetzt nicht nur darüber, selbst wenn ich es nicht gewinnen sollte, würde ich trotzdem mit meinen Freunden noch essen gehen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen kokettiert, weil er weiß schon ganz genau, dass diese Fragen immer wieder kommen und wer ihn kennt, der weiß auch, dass er dieses Ding natürlich ganz gerne gewinnen würde. Und ja, wenn er gegen Tottenham gewinnt, das wäre letzte Saison, war ja knapp, war ein verrücktes Spiel, dass, wenn ein bisschen mehr nach seinem Gusto verlaufen wäre, ein bisschen geordneter alles, hätte es vielleicht sogar funktionieren können. Aber das ist natürlich immer der Konjunktiv. Trotzdem, auf diesem Level gibt es halt keine Garantien. Da kannst du investieren, was du willst. Das ist am Ende des Tages einfach ein Glücksspiel.
Ja, klar. Ich meine, wer wüsste das besser als Pep Guardiola? Da kann man sich nun mal seine Champions League-Historie die letzten Jahre angucken. Es ist ja auch so ein bisschen so eine unleidige Diskussion. Natürlich wollen sie die Champions League gewinnen, natürlich wollen sie die Meisterschaft gewinnen und natürlich gehen sie aber halt in ein Meisterschaftsspiel auch nicht komplett auf die Champions League fokussiert rein. Ich nehme nur wahr, dass das Diskussionen sind, die jetzt langsam wieder hochkommen und das beeinflusst ja dann manchmal eine Mannschaft dann doch auch irgendwie. Aber dann lass uns doch auch mal über den letztjährigen Finalisten in der Champions League sprechen, über Tottenham. Die haben schon einen deutlichen Rückstand, wenn man jetzt davon schon sprechen möchte nach fünf Spieltagen. Sieben Punkte fehlen auf Liverpool, zwei auf City, weil man eben einfach schon zweimal unentschieden gespielt hat. Und einmal auch schon verloren. Und das war zuhause gegen Newcastle United eine Niederlage der schmerzhafteren Sorte. Wie ist da die Lage bei den Spurs?
Ja, es waren natürlich beides auch sehr unglückliche Niederlagen. Das muss man schon auch sagen. Und zuletzt wieder gewonnen, also gegen Newcastle war es ja wirklich einfach nur, die hatten, ich glaube, Newcastle hatte 27 Prozent Ballbesitz, hatte irgendwie drei Torschüsse oder sowas und Liverpool macht halt einen. Die tun sich so ein bisschen schwer, wenn sie, das ist mir aufgefallen, ich habe sie auch schon kommentiert, gegen Aston Villa. Die tun sich so ein bisschen schwer, wenn sie das Spiel machen müssen, der Gegner aber sehr tief steht. Da fehlt so ein bisschen dann die Lücke, die sie meistens nicht finden. Harry Kane braucht auch immer ein bisschen Anlauf, also es ist jetzt kein Fernando Torres oder sowas, den man wirklich in die Gasse schicken muss und der 20 Meter bis zum Tor braucht, um richtig zu explodieren, aber ein bisschen Platz für seinen Abschluss braucht er schon auch. Und wenn er dich hat und da sofort jemand steht, also geblockt werden, das ist dann einfach drin für den einen oder anderen Verteidiger, ihn zu blocken. Und da sehe ich so ein bisschen die Probleme mit Ericsson. Diese Thematik verlängerte, verlängerte nicht, die gibt es auch noch. Teilweise setzt Pochettino ihn dann wieder auf die Bank, bringt ihn erst, dann kommt er wieder, versucht was, also so richtig laufen tut es da auch noch nicht. Das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen anders eingeschätzt, weil die waren letztes Jahr schon sehr, sehr gut für meine Begriffe und dann noch sehr, sehr gut verstärkt, da hat er schon ein bisschen mehr erwartet und erhofft von den Spurs. Aber ja, ich glaube auch da wird sich im Laufe der Saison einiges noch wieder geben. Trotzdem sagen natürlich Experten wie Graham Soonest mit der Meisterschaft, war es das jetzt schon. Das finde ich ein bisschen hart. Aber ja, wenn man mal sieht, wie letzte Saison dann die Verlustraten der beiden Top-Mannschaften waren, was die liegen lassen, so viel war es nicht. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt schon so viel Rückstand hast, es wird schon schwer, das nochmal aufzuholen.
Ja, absolut. Über die Neuzugänge wollte ich mit dir noch sprechen bei den Spurs, weil da hat sich ja eben durchaus ein bisschen was verändert dahingehend, dass man jetzt viel mehr investiert hat als in den letzten Transferperioden. Also die letzte war ja die bekannte noch, wo man gar kein Euro für Transfers ausgegeben hat. Und davor war das Transferseite immer so zwischen 20 und 30 Millionen Euro. Ich nehme jetzt alle Werte von Transfermarkt.de. Und in diesem Jahr hat man richtig hingelegt, unter anderem für Tanguy N'Dambele von Olympique Lyon und für Ryan Sessegnon – Sessegnon, meine Güte, ich kann es nicht. Sessegnon, ja eben, von Fulham. Allein für die beiden, für den einen 60 Millionen Euro, für den anderen 27 Millionen Euro. Und damit Los Celso ja noch ein Spieler geliehen, auch für eine stattliche Summe von Betis Sevilla. Woher kommt es, dass die Spurs jetzt noch mal so nachgelegt haben auf dem Transfermarkt?
Letzte Saison war es klar, weil natürlich das Stadion abbezahlt werden muss. Das ist ja seit letzter Saison und das haben wir auch schon immer gesehen, dass wenn so ein Stadion nicht so pensioniert wird, von der Stadt oder vom Start oder von sonst irgendwas, sondern du musst das selbst bezahlen. Und dann ist klar, dass die Vereine das irgendwo wieder reinholen müssen, meistens dann in Transfers.
Aber die haben es doch jetzt noch nicht abbezahlt, oder?
Nein, das ist auf keinen Fall. Aber ich glaube, dass Daniel Liby, auch der Boss, dass der so ein bisschen jetzt auch das Gefühl hatte, wir sind so nah dran, wir müssen was machen. Und vielleicht so ein bisschen Investment in die Zukunft, dass man eben sagt, die Spieler sind auf dem Markt, wir müssen wieder was machen. Pochettino, das muss man auch sagen, ist jemand, der sehr viel fordert. Er hat sich letzte Saison schon hingestellt und gesagt, wir müssen was machen. Wir haben das schönste Schmuckkästchen der Welt, wir haben wirklich das schönste Haus der Welt gebaut. Jetzt brauchen wir auch gute Möbel. Das war wortwörtlich seine Aussage. Das ist ihm dann auch so ein bisschen gegeben worden. Dass man eben sagt, man muss auch was fürs Anterieur machen.
Das ist ein sehr schöner Vergleich. Das hatte ich tatsächlich nicht mitbekommen. Da hat er jetzt auf jeden Fall einen sehr teuren Stuhl bekommen oder einen Tisch. Oder je nachdem, was dann ein zentraler Mittelfeldspieler wie ein Dummbelly in dieser Metaphernwelt darstellen soll. Also die Spurs aktuell schon ein bisschen hinten dran, aber eben mehr investiert als im letzten Jahr. Dahinter wartet United. Wobei jetzt an der Tabelle müssen wir uns noch nicht aufhängen am fünften Spieltag. Aber es ist ein guter Anlass, um über United zu sprechen. Und wenn ich mir jetzt einfach nur mal die Zahlen angucke, dann sehe ich Liverpool. In Spielen mit Liverpooler Beteiligung sind 19 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von Manchester City sind 22 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von den Spurs sind 17 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen.
In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. In Spielen mit Beteiligung von United sind 12 Tore gefallen. Ja, und ich glaube, dass man da wieder so ein bisschen hin will. Das ist eigentlich so das Ziel. Also Oleg Gunnar Solzha ist sehr nah mit Alex Ferguson. Ich finde, die Transfers sprechen so ein bisschen Ferguson Sprache, dass man eben versucht, wieder ein bisschen mehr Engländer zu holen, so ein bisschen stabilere Spieler zu holen, die die Premier League schon kennen und auch so das eine oder andere britische Talent wie James zum Beispiel. Und ich glaube, dass man da so ein bisschen rauskommen möchte am Ende, dass es jetzt noch nicht so funktioniert. Okay, ich finde jetzt aber auch, dass die Mannschaft einfach auch gegenüber den anderen da oben so ein bisschen abstinkt, ehrlich gesagt. Also sie ist einfach nicht so gut wie Manchester City oder Liverpool zum Beispiel. Aber wegen die richtige Richtung ist es. Ob dann am Ende des Tages Ole Gunnar Sosa der richtige Mann dafür ist, das müssen andere entscheiden. Ich habe da so meine Zweifel, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil er mir einfach das nicht so richtig ausstrahlt, dieses, dieses ja, arrogantes, sag ich jetzt einfach mal überspitzt, dass Manchester United braucht. Also dieses Mir sein mir, was der Bayer sagen würde. Das hat Ole Gunnar Sosa für mich nicht. Der wirkt mir immer so ein bisschen zu nett, greift nicht so wirklich durch. Und man muss auch sagen, wenn man sich seine vorherigen Trainerstationen ansieht, bei Molde zum Beispiel so ganz von Erfolg gepflastert war der Weg jetzt auch nicht. Bei Cardiff sofort entlassen quasi mit dem Abstieg. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das einer ist, nach dem Abstieg. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das einer ist, der Manchester United wieder dahin führt, wo Sir Alex Ferguson sie einst mal quasi streng hat lassen.
Ich meine, dieser Vergleich mit der Ferguson-Zeit, der ist natürlich auch ein sehr ungerechter, weil das war nun mal einfach die erfolgreichste Zeit in den letzten 40 Jahren für United und war auch eine Ausnahme. Auf der anderen Seite stelle ich mir schon länger die Frage, wo möchte United eigentlich hin? Wenn ich auf finanzielle und wirtschaftliche Kennzahlen gucke, dann ist United immer unter den Top 5 Teams europaweit. Wenn ich mir dann aber die Ergebnisse angucke, sowohl in der Heimischen Liga als auch in der Champions League, dann ist da jetzt einfach schon sehr lange nichts mehr heruntergefallen und Champions League war ja nicht mal in jedem Jahr tatsächlich auch auf dem Tapet für United. Wie will United das, was es wirtschaftlich darstellt, auch wieder sportlich da sein?
Du hast ja vorher gerade angesprochen, wo wollen sie hin? Also die wollen schon wieder da oben hin. Alles, was sie tun – und sie sehen sich auch selbst da oben – alles, was sie tun, ist aufgerichtet, aber ist, dass sie wieder die Spitze der Premier League erklemmen. Die Experten in England sagen zum Beispiel, dass da noch so ein Flickenteppich von Mourinho über ist, der einfach auch den einen oder anderen Spieler versucht hat, die eine oder andere Lücke einfach zu stopfen mit Transfers. Dann von Kahl das selbe. Das ist einfach quasi noch immer so eine Mannschaft, die aus drei Trainern besteht. Aus Van Kahl, aus Mourinho und eben aus Ole Gunnar Sorge. Jeder hat irgendwie so zwei, drei Spieler in der Startformation momentan noch, und das muss erst noch zusammenwachsen. Vielleicht wird es das nie. Vielleicht muss man Social jetzt einfach derjenige sein, der übernimmt und sagt, hey, wir müssen noch mehr machen. Und ich baue mir die Mannschaft zusammen. Ich finde es auch, dass noch ein bisschen zu, ja, so ein bisschen in der Offensive die Kreativität so ein bisschen fehlt. So einer, der mir das Spiel öffnet. Pogba macht es ja immer mal wieder, aber ist auch jetzt kein richtiger Spielöffner. Geht mir halt so ein klein wenig. Das sind so zwei, drei Spieler, die vielleicht noch ein bisschen kreativer sind und das Ganze mal öffnen können. Vielleicht sind die aber auch, vielleicht sind die da, ja, mit Marcial zum Beispiel. Und Sorja ist einfach ein bisschen, ja, zu defensiv eingestellt, weiß ich auch nicht genau. Gab es auch die Kritik eben, dass er einfach jemand ist, der zu abwartend momentan das Ganze angehen lässt. Aber das sehe ich jetzt ehrlich auch nicht. Also die ersten Spiele, die ich gemacht habe und auch die letzten in der letzten Saison unter ihm, die waren eigentlich schon, er lässt sie schon laufen, eher als Mourinho das getan hat. Dementsprechend da ist momentan glaube ich eher steckt der rote Teufel im Detail. Das ist gar nicht so einfach zu analysieren.
Ja, also auch die Ergebnisse von United sind fast schon traditionell so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also du startest mit einem 4 zu 0 gegen Chelsea, wobei man da auch Ergebnis vom Spielverlauf ein bisschen getrennt betrachten muss. Dann bei den Wanderers 1 zu 1, dann zu Hause gegen Crystal Palace 1 zu 2 verloren, in Southampton in Überzahlen 1 zu 1 0 geholt, jetzt ein 1 zu 0 gegen Leicester. Es geht jetzt dann weiter in der Europa League, jetzt gegen Astana und dann bei West Ham am Wochenende. Das ist wieder alles so, wie für mich persönlich als jemand, der quasi die Premier League dann schon aus einer gewissen Distanz verfolgt, United einfach seit drei oder vier Jahren schon drauf ist. Du weißt wirklich nie, was du bekommst.
Genau, so ein bisschen ist es das. Man muss sagen, dass in der Premier League, was in der Bundesliga oft einmal der Fall ist, dass du einfach auch Mannschaften hast, die dich hinten reinstellen und nur verteidigen, das kriegst du in der Premier League nicht. Sondern die gehen alle drauf. Und wenn du eine Mannschaft bist, die die Stabilität nicht hat, dann kannst du schon überrascht werden. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was United momentan so ein bisschen trifft.
Überrascht es dich denn, dass hinter United aktuell Leicester steht mit einer noch viel spektakulären Tordifferenz von 6 zu 4 Toren? Ist es eine Momentaufnahme, wenn ich mir jetzt nur die erzielten Tore angucke mit sechs Stück nach fünf Spieltagen? Oder steckt da jetzt mehr dahinter bei Leicester?
Also die überraschen mich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Das ist so für mich einer dieser Mannschaften, die ich wirklich auch unter den ersten sieben verorte. Die Mannschaft ist – oder, machen wir top acht – Bretton Rogers hat da was implementiert, was für mich unfassbar ist. Unter Club PL waren die nicht Fisch, nicht Fleisch, nicht Fisch und nicht Chips. Kann man auch auf Englisch machen. Die Mannschaft hat wirklich kein richtiges Gesicht gehabt. Die waren kein richtig offensives Team, die waren kein richtig defensives Team. Irgendwie standen die für gar nichts. Und unter Bretton Rogers ist das ein Team mit Ballbesitzfußball geworden, der unglaublich ist. Das ist wirklich schön anzusehen. Auf der Insel sagen sie schon ein bisschen Manchester City Light, weil er auch wirklich versucht, ihm auch taktisch auf Guardiola ausgerichtet zu sein. Das gefällt mir richtig gut, was er macht. Und wenn da vorne drin es auch noch ein bisschen mehr klickt, dann viel Spaß. Das sieht in den Ansätzen schon richtig gut aus, finde ich.
Wir haben auch eine ganz faszinierende Transferstrategie gemacht, die eigentlich auch schon quasi das angekündigt hat, was man jetzt auf dem Platz sieht, mit Harry Maguire. Eine wichtige Säule in der Innenverteidigung, für sehr viel Geld an United verkauft und mit Okazaki den an Malaga gegeben. Über den haben wir im vorletzten Kurzpass gesprochen. Da ging es ja noch ein bisschen höher her. Aber wenn ich mir dann angucke, wer gekommen ist, dann haben wir Thielemans für das zentrale Mittelfeld, Perez als Spitze, Dennis Pray für das zentrale Mittelfeld. Also da ging es eben genau darum, den Fokus ein bisschen mehr auf Kreativität und Offensive zu legen, habe ich den Eindruck.
Ja, genau. Das hat ihm so ein bisschen gefehlt. Thielemans war letzte Saison schon ausgeliehen, hat überragend gespielt. Perez ist jemand, der eigentlich alles kann. Der kann auf den Außen sein, der kann auch den Zentrum Stürmer geben. Ich glaube, ich ist der erfolgreichste Stürmer 2019. Letzte Saison habe ich noch 10 Tore gemacht, glaube ich, in der Rückrunde. Also der Typ ist, bin ich ganz sicher, aber so um den Dreh rum. Und ja, das hat so ein bisschen gefehlt. Trotzdem, so viel sind es jetzt auch nicht, die neu gekommen sind. Und dennoch, dann so was draus zu machen, das spricht schon für Brandon Rodgers, der ja damals bei seiner Liverpooler Zeit am Schluss dann nicht mehr richtig gut weggekommen ist. Aber das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr guter Trainer. Und dass der bei Leicester sich wirklich niederlässt, also Respekt, ich würde das als Coup schon bezeichnen, das ist richtig gut.
Da lässt er sich nieder. Entschuldigung, den musste ich einfach mitnehmen. Wenn ich mir die Tabelle angucke, dann gibt es natürlich noch, also da gibt es eine Reihe von Teams, über die ich gerne mit dir sprechen wollen würde. Aber Chelsea und Arsenal gehören da aus unterschiedlichen Gründen mit dazu. Bei Chelsea unter anderem deswegen, weil ich mir einfach mal die Torschützen bisher angucke. 11 Tore wurden erzielt, 11 Tore hat man kassiert, daraus sind zwei Siege, zwei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage entstanden. Die erfolgreichsten Torschützen sind Tammy Abraham, 21 Jahre, Mason Mount, 20 Jahre und Fikao Tomori, 21 Jahre. Kann es sein, dass diese Transfersperre Chelsea vielleicht sogar gut tut?
Dieser schöne uralte deutsche Spruch aus der Not eine Tugend machen. Ja, also ehrlich gesagt, Uli und ich, also mein Bruder, der es bei Sonja auch letztes Jahr noch kommentiert hat, wir fordern das schon seit Jahren eigentlich. Also die sind in den U-Mannschaften so erfolgreich wie kaum ein anderes Team auf der Insel. Die haben unglaubliche Nachwuchsjahrgänge, auch wenn man sich ansieht Ruben Loft ist chic oder Kalamatsen Odoi und so weiter und so fort. Das sind sehr, sehr gute Fußballer, teilweise auch natürlich Spieler wie Luis Baker oder sowas dann weggegeben. Die haben eigentlich immer alles abgerissen und trotzdem haben die nie eine Chance bekommen, weil ja, glaube ich, jährlich 25 Spieler verliehen werden. Irgendwo in die Welt oder nach Europa und das ist halt so ein bisschen schade gewesen, dass diese Spieler die Chance nicht bekommen haben. Die drei, die du angesprochen hast, Tommori, Mount und Abraham, haben letzte Saison 2. Liga gespielt und sind jetzt plötzlich die Heißbringer in der ersten Mannschaft bei Chelsea. Also das ist wirklich Lempardts Verdank, Lempardts zu verdanken, dass er diesen Spielern einfach diese Gelegenheit gibt, weil das wäre, glaube ich, unter Sari Niso gekommen, der bei Callum Hudson und Deutschland rum überlegt, ob er ihn überhaupt mal bringen soll, was eigentlich keiner verabschieden soll. Und Chelsea fast wahrscheinlich den talentiertesten Spieler seit Ewigkeiten gekostet hätte, wenn er zu den Bayern gegangen wäre. Auch er hat ihn immer noch nicht verlängert. Also insofern, ich hoffe, dass das am Ende nicht auszahlt für Chelsea. Was ich so ein bisschen Angst davor habe, ist, dass dieser Club irgendwann mal die Geduld verliert. Ich hoffe, dass es nicht passiert, aber das kann natürlich schon sein. Abamovic ist sehr erfolgsversessen. Da muss man auch noch sagen, dass selbst Sarri, der ja eigentlich eine gute Saison gespielt hat, ist am Ende dann weg, ist weg. Der hat sich für die Champions League qualifiziert, der hat die Europa League gewonnen und trotzdem heißt es am Ende des Tages, ciao, kann zurück nach Italien gehen. Und da habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Angst davor, dass man vielleicht sagt, ja, Rang 6 ist ein Übergangsjahr, hm, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob das so toll ist. Und dass man dann vielleicht sogar sich selbst von Frank Lampard trennen könnte, was ich nicht hoffe, was ich vielleicht auch nicht glaube, weil er natürlich schon einen Lampard-Bonus hat, einen Legenden-Bonus. Und ich auch wirklich, wirklich, wirklich hoffe, dass sie ihm die Chance geben, weil das ein Trainer ist, der sich natürlich auch erst noch richtig hundertprozentig finden muss, der aber super Ansätze hat.
Ja, da kommt jetzt sicherlich auch die Champions League-Niederlage zu Hause gegen Valencia mit rein, mit verschossenem Strafstoß auch noch. Also es wird keine einfache Saison für Chelsea, aber das wäre ja auch überraschend, wenn das jetzt irgendwie einfach mit Lampard von Anfang an alles perfekt erklappen würde. Da sind wir halt auch noch sehr früh in der Saison. Bin ich auch gespannt, wie geduldig man da dann ist in London beim FC Chelsea. Über Arsenal würde ich gerne mit dir kurz noch sprechen, weil die ja auch der Gegner von Eintracht Frankfurt sind in der Europa League am Donnerstagabend. Auf was darf sich denn da die SGE freuen?
Auf eine Menge Fehlpässe. Ich hab das Spiel zusammengefasst gegen Watford am Wochenende. Also das war wirklich an Naivität nicht zu überbieten. Die ersten Viertelstunde haben sie komplett verschlafen, haben dann zwei Tore gemacht, das nimmt gar nichts. Auf das muss die Eintracht aufpassen. Je nachdem, wer spielt, kann es sein, dass die Obermeerangs dieser Welt geschont werden. Aber dann, wie sie in der zweiten Halbzeit mit der 2.0-Führung hinten rausspielen, mit einer Naivität, die ich so lange nicht mehr gesehen hab, führen die Abstöße immer kurz aus. Und Zokatis spielt dem Gegner den Ball direkt vor die Füße 2 zu 1. Und am Schluss hat er sogar noch einen Elfmeter verschuldet von David Luiz. Also das war wirklich – Emmerich Aubameyang hat am Schluss auch gesagt, er hat noch nie das Gefühl gehabt, ein Spiel so verschenkt zu haben wie da. Und das ist eben der FC Arsenal noch immer so ein bisschen diese Naivität. Man sieht, was die Mannschaft vorne kann. Die schießen aus dem Nichts, zwei Tore, eiskalt, wunderschön rausgespielt. Der Ball von Mesut Özil in die Tiefe, Mäitland Neis liegt drüber. Unglaublich, also richtig wie Arsene Menga es geliebt hätte. Und du hast aber auch die andere Seite nach hinten so naiv und so unbedarft, dass du dir echt manchmal denkst, wie das ist ein Pflichtspiel. Das ist kein Testspiel, sondern du musst es schon ein bisschen mit Ernsthaftigkeit angehen. Karin Tschaka, der auch da, weiß gar nicht in welchem Spiel es war, die sind Elfmeter verschuldet, gegen Tottenham sogar. Also das sind immer wieder so Aktionen drin, wo sie einfach nicht mitdenken, den Elfmeter verursachen oder sich einfach so dämlich anstellen, dass das Gegenteuer quasi fast schon ein Muss ist. Und ja, das ist Hopp oder Top bei Arsenal, das muss man sagen. Also sie haben beides in sich. Die Frage ist, welche Seite sie zeigen werden.
Und ist die Özil-Diskussion, ob er spielt, ob er nicht spielt, ist das ein valides Thema auch für diese Saison? Also rein den Zahlen nach hatte er jetzt einmal 71 Minuten. Es gab ja auch immer mal wieder ja aber auch Gründe, warum er nicht im Kader stand, mehr oder weniger kreative. Ist es für dich ein Thema?
Also es wird ein Thema werden. Es war immer eins und es wird immer eins werden, weil Una Emery jetzt nicht unbedingt sein größter Fan ist. Der letzte Saison ja auch mehr oder minder immer mal wieder angedeutet, dass das nicht so unbedingt sein Typ ist und dass er einfach auch ein bisschen zu wenig nach hinten macht und dass es so auch, glaube ich, mit dem Training, mit der Trainingsleistung war auch nicht ganz einverstanden. Das ist, das wird ein Thema bleiben, nur die Diskussion hatte ich letzte Woche dann auch mit einem Kollegen. Du musst halt wissen, wenn du Mesut Özil aufstellst, was du bekommst. Du bekommst da keinen Bauarbeiter. Das ist so. Du bekommst einen Architekten. Wenn du den, wenn du den, wenn du auch ein Spielhaben bist, das ein bisschen verspielter ist, dann setz ihn ein gerne. Wenn nicht, wenn du jemanden willst, der eben Bauarbeiter ist, dann setz auf Lucas Torreira oder wem auch immer. Aber das finde ich immer so ein bisschen unfair, dass man bei Özil sagt, ja der ist so und so und wir wissen ja alle, der rennt so ein bisschen rum und so weiter. Aber zum Beispiel Harry Kane ist ja auch keiner, der irgendwie groß dribbelt, der irgendwie groß nach hinten arbeitet, der irgendwie groß Dinge macht. Der macht eine Sache, der erst nimmt den Ball, legt ihn sich vor und haut ihn in den Kopf. Eine Sache, die macht er perfekt, ja die macht er perfekt. Aber das macht Mesh und Özil auch, auf seine Art und Weise. Es ist nur eine andere Sache. Er versucht das Spiel immer im Laufen zu halten, versucht immer sofort direkt weiter zu spielen, ist in seinen Pässen sehr uneitel, ist keiner, der versucht immer den Assist zu bekommen, sondern auch da letzte Woche eben gegen Wattford. Er ist der Mann, der den Ball zum Ball spielt. Er ist der Mann, der den Assist vorbereitet. Und das ist Mesh und Özil. Das taucht in keiner Statistik auf, das taucht auch nicht in der Statistik auf. Aber er ist jemand, der sehr, sehr wichtig ist, der das Spiel öffnet, der das Spiel verändert und der das Spiel schnell macht. Und das macht er perfekt. Wenn du sagst, das ist mir wichtig, ich brauche so einen Typen, dann lass ihn spielen. Wenn du sagst, er läuft mir aber zu wenig nach hinten, kann ich auch verstehen, dass da draußen Zuschauer sind, die sagen, mir macht er zu wenig. Ich persönlich mag halt, dass ganz gerne einen Spieler zu haben, der dir was öffnen kann. Das ist zum Beispiel was, was eben United fehlt. Mit einem Özil, vielleicht mit einem kreativeren, der diese schnellen Außenmal einsetzt, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Also das ist schon jemand, der in der Mannschaft noch was geben kann. Aber du brauchst natürlich ein Gerüst, das auffängt, was Özil dir nicht gibt.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns doch einfach mal an, was Arsene dagegen die Eintracht machen wird. Ich werde auch Dani Ceballos mir mal näher angucken, der bei mir bei der U21 EM sehr, sehr gut gefallen. Und da bin ich gespannt, welche Rolle der jetzt bei Arsene spielt. Welche Teams stechen denn noch für dich ins Auge? Was glaubst du, sollten wir jetzt noch besprechen, dass wir so ein bisschen, ohne dass wir jetzt über jedes Team reden können, dafür wird uns dann doch die Zeit abgerundet haben, diese ersten fünf Spieltage in der Premier League. Wer ist da noch wichtig, deine Meinung nach?
Ja, es gibt schon noch eine Menge. Norwich ist ganz nett. Ich glaube auch Newcastle mit Sicherheit ist auch interessant. Champions United ist interessant. Aber auch natürlich Wolverhampton, die gar nicht rauskommen da unten. Also es gibt eigentlich schon eine Menge Geschichten, die momentan noch auf der Straße liegen. Du darfst dir gerne was aussuchen.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt einfach durch. Lass mal mit Norwich anfangen, mit dem unfassbaren Thema Pukki, der in der Phase seines Lebens ist. Sechs Premier League Tore hat er jetzt schon erzielt. Insgesamt hat Norwich erst neun Tore erzielt. Da kann man auch ungefähr den Einfluss von Pukki auf den Erfolg seiner Mannschaft sehen. Jetzt gekrönt von diesem Sieg gegen City. Was steckt denn hinter dem Volk von Norwich?
Ja, das ist natürlich, also ich finde es sehr beeindruckend. Daniel Fark hat das vorhin so gesagt, wir sind wahrscheinlich der finanzschwächste Aufsteiger aller Zeiten. Die haben, ich weiß gar nicht, ich hab's letztes Mal getwittert, was die in Transfersummen die Aufstellung gegen Manchester City gekostet hat. Die erste Elf, das sind, glaube ich, unter fünf Millionen, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, also das ist fast gar nichts. Und trotzdem gewinnen die gegen eine Mannschaft, die das Zehnfache kostet, fast das Zehnfache, das Hundertfache kostet. Und das ist natürlich schon beeindruckend. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die jeder einzelne Spieler kann was mit dem Ball, nicht auf dem aller, allerhöchsten Niveau. Und das man jetzt sagen kann, okay, aber ein paar schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gehoben. Aus dieser, haben diese Selbstbewusstsein, wir können gegen jeden was machen. Und das hat Daniel Farkin implementiert. Und die haben es sogar gegen City geschafft, dass sie da eben immer sich wieder Chancen rausspielen.
Und sie haben sich immer hinten rauskomplimiert.
Auch gegen Liverpool, am ersten Spieltag, genau. Auch gegen Liverpool zum Beispiel, am ersten Spieltag. Da haben alle gesagt, jetzt werden die richtig auseinandergenommen und ha ha und viel Spaß. Und das ist ja gar nichts und so weiter. Ich habe damals schon getwittert, sei vorsichtig mit dieser Mannschaft, weil die hat wirklich genug spielerische Klasse, um sich auch gegen große Teams Chancen zu erarbeiten. Und das haben wir gesehen. Die brauchen nicht viel, um was zu machen. Und Temu Pukki ist momentan in überragender Verfassung. Und dann klappt es halt, wenn du jemanden hast, der das Ding dann reinbuxiert. Dann funktioniert es.
Also die sechs beste Passquote der Liga nach den bisherigen fünf Spielen. Das zeigt eben so ein bisschen den Fokus auf ein sauberes Passspiel. Bei Besitzspiel jetzt nicht unbedingt, aber sehr gut im Umschalten. Allerdings auch die zweitmeisten Schüsse in Richtung des eigenen Tores zugelassen. Übrigens nur Arsenal ist da aktuell noch schlechter nach fünf Spieltagen. Also das sieht für mich von außen aus so ein bisschen aus, als ob da jetzt auch ein paar Dinge zusammengekommen sind. Nach Expected Points wären sie irgendwo kurz vor der Abstiegszone jetzt in der Tabelle. Also ein bisschen tiefer.
Ja, aber das ist doch mutig. Also es ist doch echt cool, dass es ein Team noch gibt. Zum Beispiel Sheffield ist genau das Gegenteil. Die versuchen sich so über Unentschieden und über eher ein hartes Spiel, sich Punkte zu erarbeiten, einfach zu hamstern, immer mal wieder unentschieden einzufahren, um am Ende über dem Strich zu bleiben. Und Norwich sagt einfach entweder ganz oder gar nicht. Wir haben das implementiert, wir sind so aufgestiegen, warum sollen wir jetzt was ändern? Und das finde ich schon sehr beeindruckend, dass das ebenso funktioniert. Du hast da vorne einen Pucki, du hast einen Buendia, der ist überragend, Todd Cantwell, ein junger Mann aus der eigenen Jugend, den keiner kannte. Der hat sich da reingespielt, der überall abgelehnt worden ist, der aus Jugendmannschaften rausgeschmissen worden ist. Und der spielt momentan überragend auf. Dann hast du einen Pucki, der auf Schalke überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, der dann irgendwann in Dänemark gelandet ist. Kurioserweise sagt er, der Grund meines Erfolges ist Alex Zorniger. Kein Spaß. Der hat mir quasi wieder gezeigt, wie ich mich zu verhalten habe auf dem Feld und auch abseits des Feldes. Und seither bin ich ein ganz anderer Typ und viel professioneller, als ich noch auf Schalke war. Also das ist schon sehr witzig, dass du solche Leute einfach findest. Es sind mehrere solche Typen, die eigentlich – Christoph Zimmermann, der Innenverteidiger, der hat schon angefangen mit seinem Lehramtsstudium und hat dann einen Anruf bekommen, hey magst du nicht bei uns Champions-League spielen? Wir wollen aufsteigen. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja gut, dann probiere ich es halt nochmal. Also das ist schon sehr irre, dass du solche Typen einfach hast und das Farke einfach so kühn ist zu sagen, auch mit diesen Typen, wir können ja Fußball spielen, die haben genug drauf. Die Engländer kannten vorher keinen einzigen dieser Spieler, die der geholt hat und jetzt sind das alles Helden.
Faszinierend. Und weil du Sheffield gerade schon angesprochen hast, die finde ich insofern bemerkenswert. Aktuell stehen die auch mit 5 Punkten wunderbar da für einen Aufsteiger. Du hast ja auch gerade schon ein bisschen den Kontrast zu Norwitsch angesprochen. Gleichzeitig sieht man aber, wenn man sich so etwas wie Expected Goals anschaut, dass Sheffield sehr, sehr gut in der Liga dasteht. Also nach Expected Goals liegen sie aktuell auf Platz 5, aber sind auch erst 5 Spiele gespielt, also ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Aber da scheint mir auch eigentlich ein ganz gutes Gerüst da zu stehen für einen Aufsteiger.
Absolut, also Chris Wilder ist auf jeden Fall jemand, der weiß, was er tut. Das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Trainer, der in den unteren Ligen eigentlich alles durchhatte und der macht das richtig, richtig gut. Und da bin ich auch gespannt, wie weit das noch gehen kann. Also das ist von der Mannschaft her, finde ich, ja so mit das Schwächste. Das ist, glaube ich, ungenommen. Also das sind wirklich alles Championship-Fußballer. Das sagt er auch selbst, das ist so ein bisschen unser Ding. Wir können uns bei den Großen nicht bedienen. Wir müssen einfach versuchen, aus der zweiten Liga Spieler zu holen, die quasi in der Premier League dann den nächsten Schritt machen. Das hat er getan. Aber jeder Einzelne auf diesem Feld ist darauf ausgerichtet, alles zu geben, zu jedem Zeitpunkt und niemals loszulassen. Das ist so ein bisschen quasi der konterre Ansatz zu Norwich, die einfach sagen, ja ist okay, wir bleiben einfach immer cool und spielen dann trotzdem. Und bei denen ist es einfach so ein bisschen mit Fight und dann auch mal wieder so in die Tiefe gehen. Aber das ist schon eine Mannschaft, die mich auch sehr beeindruckt, die mich auch letzte Saison beeindruckt. Als die da oben standen, dachte ich mir, ja klar, also die werden sich nicht halten, da wird Leeds steigen, da wird und so weiter. Und die haben sich direkt, das muss ich noch mal sagen, die haben sich direkt für die Premier League qualifiziert, ja über Rang 2. Die mussten nicht durch die Playoffs gehen. Aston Villa musste das. Und das ist echt Wahnsinn. Also das hätte ich niemals gedacht, dass die sich so halten können. Und da muss man echt sagen, Hut ab vor Chris Wilder und dem, was er da gemacht hat. Das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Und wer sich an Storylines neben dem Feld erfreuen kann, der kann mal googeln Kevin McCabe versus Prince Abdullah. Die streiten sich gerade darum, wer jetzt eigentlich Eigentümer sein darf.
Vor Gericht sogar.
Jaja, genau.
Die reden nicht mehr miteinander und müssen dann vor Gericht klären. Beide haben 50 Prozent der Aktien und müssen dann vor Gericht klären lassen, wer denn jetzt eigentlich eine Entscheidung trifft, wenn sie denn fallen muss. Das ist mega witzig. Ja, aber auch irgendwo traurig.
Genau, und des traditionellen Footballs.
Auch irgendwo traurig, ja.
Ja, genau. Aber das ist noch so eine Neben-Story bei Sheffield. Dann hast du schon Newcastle kurz angesprochen. Die sind nicht gut in die Saison gestartet, mit drei Niederlagen, einem Unentschieden und nur einem Sieg. Und daraus eben jetzt nur vier Punkte und auch nur vier Tore erzielt in diesen fünf Spielen. Was ist da bei Newcastle los?
Also die ersten beiden Spiele, würde ich sagen, die kannst du verlieren. Also das sind natürlich Niederlagen, die sind, wenn man sich die genauer betrachtet, natürlich jetzt dämlich, aber du hast einen neuen Trainer. Du bist von Rafa Benitez auf Steve Boos gewechselt. Ich finde, du kannst die ersten zwei Spiele verlieren.
Also gegen Arsenal 0 zu 1 und dann bei Norwich.
Das gegen Arsenal habe ich gesehen. Das hätte auch 0-0 ausgehen können. Gegen Norwich okay, haben wir auch gesehen. Die haben da halt einfach wieder mal echt eiskalt das Spiel gemacht. Das war halt diese Pukigala. Und dann kommen zwei Spiele, die eigentlich viel charakteristischer für die Mannschaft sind. Gegen Tottenham, da sieht man, was die Mannschaft eigentlich kann. Die stellen sich hinten rein, und zwar sehr diszipliniert. Wie auch gegen Liverpool, die erste Halbzeit. Und lassen dann wirklich nichts mehr zu. Kommen einmal vor das Tor, Joey Linton macht den und das bringen die über die Zeit. Das war ein überragendes Spiel. Taktisch echt super. Und sehr diszipliniert. Gegen Watford holst du immer einen Punkt, das ist auch okay. Also, der Newcastle ist keine Mannschaft, die jedes Spiel mit einem Dreier beenden muss. Und gegen Liverpool, muss ich sagen, die erste Viertelstunde war wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Man kann sogar ausweiten, glaube ich, auf die ersten 20, 25 Minuten. Die waren richtig gut. Und haben das machen, dieses Tor. Es war wieder so ein Moment, dass sie einfach den Großen schocken. Und dann kam dieser Moment, dass man sagt, Liverpool ist einfach noch eine Klasse höher einzuschätzen als Newcastle. Und so kommt dann auch dieses Ergebnis zustande, dass du irgendwann 1 zu 3 verlierst. Aber eigentlich ist Newcastle eine Mannschaft, die was drauf hat. So ist es nicht. Da sind schon ein paar Spieler drin, die was können. Und Steve Bruce ist natürlich auch das, mit dem ich mich eingehen, beschäftigt vor der Partie. Er war elfte Wahl, wenn man den Boulevard-Medien Glauben schenken darf. Da waren Namen wie Mourinho, wie Sean Dice, wie Eddie Howe usw. Er war zumindest – das ist verbrieft – nicht erste Wahl. Er ist ein Trainer, der auf der Insel mehr oder minder belächelt wird. Er ist Spianship-Trainer. Es gab ein paar Experten, die in Expertenrunden gefragt wurden. Einfach nur diese Schnellrate-Runde. Würdest du Steve Bruce als Trainer holen, egal bei welchem Verein du bist? Nein. Also alle haben Nein gesagt. Das ist jemand, der einfach im Man-Management beragend ist. Ich glaube, es wäre ein super Co-Trainer, mit den Spielern zu sprechen. Taktisch sagt er selbst von sich, I'm not so much into tactics. Das hat er 2011 in einem Interview mal gesagt. Also ich bin nicht der große Taktiker und das sieht man auch so ein bisschen. Aber seine Mannschaften kommen immer über Wille, über Kampf und auch über Stabilität. Das ist so sein Ding. Und wenn ich Liverpooler-Gender gewesen wäre, hätte das vielleicht sogar funktionieren können. Weil die standen eigentlich ganz ordentlich, aber Liverpool hat die irgendwann einfach mal geknackt und dann war es halt vorbei. Aber ich hoffe, dass für Newcastle und für diesen Verein, dass sie sich in der Liga halten können und dass sie eben diese Stabilität finden. Weil das schon ein Team ist, das in die Liga gehört. Sie selbst sehen sich in der ersten Hälfte, das sehe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit dieser Mannschaft. Und auch nicht mit diesem Trainer, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Aber das ist schon eine Truppe, die eigentlich mit dem Abstieg jetzt nicht unbedingt was zu tun haben sollte, in allerletzter Konsequenz, wenn die alles auf die Straße bringen, was sie haben. Das ist dann die Frage, ob sie das können.
Auch ein ganz interessanter Wechsel von Benitez zu Bruce. Da hat man jetzt eine andere Geschmacksrichtung an Trainer angekauft. Zuletzt noch kurz, wenn ich mir die Tabellenende aktuell angucke, dann fällt mir vor allem die Wolverhampton Wanderers vor allem auf. Die sind in der letzten Saison noch auf Platz 7 eingelaufen, jetzt eben vorletzter, haben noch keinen Sieg geholt und 6 zu 10 Tore. Kann man das an irgendwas festmachen, dass es so schlecht gelaufen ist bei Wolverhampton bisher?
Also ich habe auch in der letzten Saison ein paar Spiele gemacht, ich habe in der Aufstiegssaison ganz viel von denen gemacht. Das ist eigentlich so eine Truppe, die immer so ein bisschen, ja, die immer so ein bisschen auf der Rasierklinge tanzt. Die versuchen oftmals die erste Halbzeit so ein bisschen, also wirklich, die versuchen oft die erste Halbzeit so ein bisschen zu verschlafen, um den Gegner so ein bisschen in Sicherheit zu wiegen und dann in der zweiten Halbzeit die auszukontern und richtig, richtig schnell das Spiel dann für sich zu entscheiden. Und das hat halt überhaupt noch nicht funktioniert. Also gegen United zum Beispiel auch die erste Halbzeit, da war ich geschockt. Das war gar nichts. Und in der zweiten Halbzeit müssten sie das Spiel eigentlich gewinnen. Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was ihnen fehlt. Diese Kälte vor dem Tor, dieses auch wieder mehr, dann wirklich das Spiel zu übernehmen. Wenn ich die Taktik fahre, zu sagen, komm, jetzt lassen wir die erst mal kommen, und in der zweiten Halbzeit werden wir das Sturm drehen, dann muss halt in der zweiten Halbzeit auch mehr kommen. Und da, finde ich, ist diese Balance noch nicht da, sondern das ist so ein bisschen alles noch zu wackelig und auch nicht sicher genug. Und vielleicht müsste man daran die Taktik auch mal umschalten und zu sagen, hey, komm, wir versuchen es auch mal anders. Das ist mir manchmal zu sehr Plan A. Und Plan B haben sie nicht wirklich. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Also er lässt immer mit dieser Fünferkette spielen, die in der Offensive dann quasi eine Dreierkette wird und dann unvermittelt wird davor. Das ist schon sehr oft dasselbe. Und ich habe zum Uli letztes Jahr schon gesagt, ich warte, bis diese Mannschaft dekodiert wird. Und das ist so ein bisschen jetzt, glaube ich, der Fall.
Und dabei hat man echt einiges investiert. Also nur Aston Villa, City und Arsenal haben noch ein niedrigeres Transfer. Sei du bei den Wanderers sind wieder einige Spieler gekommen. Und natürlich auch wieder Portugiesen. Also das war ja schon im letzten Jahr so, dass das so ein bisschen ein Outlet wurde für portugiesische Spieler. Hängt natürlich auch mit dem Trainer zusammen. Woher kommt denn eigentlich das Geld für diese Transfers? Also das Transfer Seido liegt laut Transfermarkt.de irgendwo bei minus 93 Millionen Euro.
Also in erster Linie liegt das Geld an den Besitzer. Die Fosun-Gruppe ist ein Koklomerat im Finanzsektor. Die haben insgesamt, was man so glauben darf, eine Schwere von 60 Milliarden Euro. Also da ist Geld da. Das ist jetzt quasi nicht das Problem. Die wollen auch, so hieß es innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre, als sie angetreten sind, dass sie Champions League spielen wollen. Also die meinen das wirklich ernst. Dazu kommt, dass sie mit dem Berater Mendez zusammenarbeiten. Genau, das war die Quote. Auch z.B. mit Nuno Espirito Santo, der denen gehört, oder mit João Mutinho, mit Rui Patricio, der diese Spieler einfach immer wieder anlockt. Das Ganze wurde auch schon von der EFL kritisch beäugt, von der UEFA, glaube ich, auch, wenn man nicht alles täuscht. Da wird einfach immer mal wieder der eine oder andere Portugieser angelockt und das Geld dann eben von oben gegeben, um das Team dann eben auch quasi richtig da zu platzieren. Aber sie haben es natürlich auch richtig gut gemacht in den letzten Jahren, das muss man schon auch sagen. Also das ist wirklich nicht einfach nur blind Spieler kaufen und sagen, komm, der hat einen netten Namen, sondern das ist schon alles wirklich mit Bedacht, weil die auch wirklich Spieler holen mit Tempo und auch mit Kreativität versuchen, da eben was zu kommen. Deswegen finde ich dieses Projekt, wenn man es mal so bezeichnen möchte, finde ich höchst interessant, dass man eben wirklich da schon auch mit Intellect Spieler kauft und nicht einfach nur einen holt, weil er eben machbar ist.
Ach, das ist ein schönes Schlusswort jetzt einfach für den Kurzpass. Das lassen wir so stehen und schauen uns in Ruhe an, was mit Wolverhampton noch so passieren wird. Sie haben sich ja für die Europa League immerhin schon mal qualifiziert. Da geht es jetzt dann los gegen Braga in der Europa League. Und die Saison ist ja noch jung. Joachim, das war kompakt, das war wunderbar. Ich danke dir sehr, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Danke für deine Zeit.
Jederzeit wieder, ich danke.
Da komme ich darauf zurück, darauf kannst du dich verlassen. Man kann dir folgen als at jogehebel auf Twitter. Man kann dir lauschen bei Sky, wenn du die Premier League überträgst. Und das war er, der Kurzpass Nummer 135. Herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und wenn ihr in die Rasenfunk-Geschichte eintauchen wollt, heute, exakt vor zwei Jahren, ist ein Kurzpass mit Giovane Elber erschienen. Kurzpass Nummer 40, unglaublich. Da sind mal eben 95 Folgen dazwischen noch veröffentlicht worden. Na ja, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Macht's gut, ciao!